you don't have to be afraid of what's  inside of you and we often get very  afraid of what's inside of us especially  after trauma is if there's something  magical just off I can't see in my  peripheral vision and if I like really  look at that that's the I'll start  crying and never stop or I'll stop  functioning and it's just not how it  works it's just not how we work so if we  honor and validate that that's in us but  also recognize that it's not actually  true that confronting the thing that  makes shame or fear is going to make us  fall apart and in fact quite the  opposite we don't have to be afraid  of it and we don't have to rush head  long and you know you can talk to  somebody a little bit or you can write a  little bit you know we can approach it  like anything else you know judiciously  carefully reflectively that's how we  make ourselves healthier yeah